first of all I thank Jess because one
thing that you should do when you're
organizing a conference is to give
somebody a Dan analysis task which is
really really important to the
conference it involves web scraping and
telling somebody who tell anybody who
the winner is
I wasn't stressful at all um but no
seriously it was like yeah so before I
get started I wanted to bring like you
know it's hard to fall follow Mauro
because you know she's outgoing and I'm
like dirty but I didn't want to get
serious like too much at first but there
was like something like something really
important that came up yesterday it has
to be addressed so we were talking about
snakes and and it came up into the talks
and so you know no one's saying like I
kinda know what the name is snake right
and so I have so I have some expertise
here that we we just got a ball python
and my son decided to name it doodle
ramen noodle so I like the thing that
we're really good at naming animals so
if you need another long name for a pet
let me know and we'll hook you up anyway
he did make the party hat so yeah all
right so what are we here to talk about
or one am I here to talk about we're
here to talk about modeling and
resampling which should be no surprise
anybody since it's me so what I want to
talk about is how do you measure
performance between models I do a lot of
predictive modeling like machine
learning stuff and that's usually where
I focus but the the stuff that I've
talked about here is really really
represented you could use this on
anything I have examples on the website
for like you know basic survival models
and things like that but I want to talk
about a way to use the kind of an odd
way to use Bayesian analysis to take
different models in say in practical
ways which one's better or how different
they are so it's a way to quantify model
performance okay so a lot of times you
know we get this data set and we build
some models maybe build like three
models and at the end of the day we want
to say oh this one is better than that
one so we compute some sort of measure
performance like the accuracy or the
Herrington or C curve or maybe you're
doing Leaning regression would you like
r-squared or something like that and so
we usually have like you know if you
follow like the machine learning
approach good idea is to take your data
set and split it off into a training set
which you build your model
in a test set which you wait till the
very end to evaluate the amount of
performance on so two different sets of
data and you know the question is when I
have a test set and I calculate like the
I don't know like the R squared
you know you might win some sort of
measure but certainty on that so let's
say you get an R squared for one model
that's 0.9 and another model it's a
point 9 1 like okay that's a percentage
point higher like is that a big deal you
know is that better should I you know
because it might be that the the one at
the lower R squared is a model you like
more for various reasons like maybe it's
really fast or something like that so so
a lot of times what we want to do is we
would put estimate some uncertainty on
this I kind of a confidence interval or
something like that on the R squared so
we can say like yeah these two things
are really different or they're not but
the problem is you have like one data
set and for the most part unless you're
going to do some bootstrapping and
things like that
it's really hard to put estimates of
noise on these things and then
compounded with that is like traditional
like frequentist or non Bayesian
approach to doing this would be like to
put a confidence interval in these
numbers I just want to remind everybody
like what a confidence enroll actually
is which is basically you know if I were
to have repeated this experiment in some
alternate reality like a thousand times
you know a 90% confidence overall you
would say 90% of those times the value
would fall between these two numbers
so try telling that to like a scientist
or somebody they're like what like what
are you talking about and that's not
really what we care about what they what
they typically interpret that as is
something like saying well there's a 90%
probability that the true r-squared is
between these two values and those are
two very different things
but luckily Bayesian analysis incredible
integrals and things like that will give
you the latter more simple
interpretation where you get an interval
and it's really the the probability a
certain degree probability that the true
values between two numbers based on your
assumptions and so that's you know I'm
not like full-scale Bayesian yet but I'm
getting there I feel like there's some
things I still couldn't do with that and
I was really hoping this talk wasn't
following Gelman or but even worse
before gentleman so yeah so I want to
use some Bayesian analysis and to do
that and so let's see how it goes but
before we get there we got to talk about
data a little bit so a lot of time we
can resample datasets so we have you
ever heard of cross-validation the
bootstrap what people do is they'll take
a training set their data and they'll do
this
Appling procedures that like basically
our Catholic simulation procedures they
with some methodology leave out somewhat
random proportion of the data and you
build a model on that and the data that
you didn't use to build the model is
what you predict on and get your
measures of performance your summary
statistics and then you put them all
back in the pot and you do like another
resample and so on so you're basically
taking like simulated subsets of your
data that you build your model on and
then you predict on the other set that
was left out and at the end of the day
if you do let's say ten iterations of
your sampling you get like ten R
Squared's and it turns out that the
average of those usually is a good
measure of future performance okay so
that's what all resampling is it's a way
usually to get measures of performance
on the data set before you get to your
test set okay which is computationally
can be kind of a lot sometimes but it's
extremely helpful and so this is just a
little schematic of like how we use our
data we get you know somebody brings us
a CSV file or like a few minutes ago
some he says please scrape these two
websites to tell me what's going on so
you got all your data and typically
people separate it into a training set
and a test set and the resampling
happens on the training set and so you
can see you probably wouldn't do three
resamples that's not very much but
that's what I could fit on this page and
so like on the first three sample there
on the left now I sort of tried to
invent some terminology a few or like
last year because people talk about the
training and test set and resampling and
then it gets confused with the original
training and test set so what I've
decided to do is to call these things
that happen in resampling the analysis
set which is what you build your model
on is like the resampled version of your
training set and the assessment set is
like your resampled version of the test
set okay so on the first resample you
take a little bit of data you build a
model that's the analysis set and then
you predict what's in the assessment set
and you put it back in and then the next
resample has maybe a similar or maybe
mutually exclusive set of data that's in
the analysis set and so on okay so the
different types of cross-validation or
the different types of resampling
cross-validation to bootstrap they
mainly different how those we samples
are created okay so what happens is
let's say you're going to build a bunch
of models let's say you're doing
regression you're going to build four
models so what people typically do is
they would take those four models and
would fit them each time on each one
these resamples and so then you know for
this first analysis set on the left
you know you'd fit your four different
models and you get four different
predictions on the assessment set which
would rely resulting like four different
R squares and so that's what happens
when you do resampling is the first
iteration of resampling you get these
four estimates of r-squared the second
estimate you get four different
estimates of r-squared that are all
based on the assessment set and so on so
you go to sort of round robin and again
your your overall estimate of
performance for the first model would be
the average of those are squares across
all three samples okay
so here's the thing is like if you don't
do resampling and you want to build some
sort of probabilistic statement about
like hey my performance on this model is
you know 90% R squared plus or minus
something you kind of need R applicants
right does anybody ever come to you with
the data set and they're like could you
analyze this sounds like one number
that's kind of where we're at if we
don't do resampling so what we'll do is
we use resampling which we might be
doing anyway to tune models as a way to
get replicates of what this thing we're
trying to measure and get uncertainty
for and that's how this happens and so
what we end up with is sort of like a
two-way layout basically so this is I
have a post all the code in all this
this is the Ames housing data set has
anybody ever heard that I'm hoping like
in five years it'll be the next iris set
or the next empty cars because I'm so
tired of it but it's a data set that it
was from late 2013 that this guy
basically scraped the website of the
Iowa assessor's office and and it was
using a casual competition and so we put
an R package together for it and
basically we're trying to predict sale
prices of houses I'm not going to go
into the models or what I did or what I
didn't do but what you would do in this
resampling process is I use 10-fold
cross-validation which means we have ten
separate resamples instead of three like
I showed in the last page and what
you'll see is there are rows for each
one of these resamples so this is using
the our sample package so fold one is
the first resample full two is a second
and then I fit a bag tree random forest
and a multivariate adaptive regression
splines model to these data so in the
first fold these are the R Squared's
that we calculated for the assessment
set the first time around
the second reasonable here
or the assessments at our squares and so
on so we have like a full data matrix
and so if you think about this as kind
of your source data at this point like
if somebody brought you in an OVA model
life it would look like this the only
real difference is the data the things
that we've measured that we want to
analyze now is not the original sale
price data it's the actual R squares
which are what are in this table okay so
now we're going to analyze the summary
statistics of our models as if they were
our original data or at least data that
we want to get performance measures on
and contrast against different models so
we can treat this like an ANOVA model
the complication here is that there's
usually a bunch of what we call resample
to resample effect is you might have one
resample that all the models have
trouble with so it's almost uniformly
low performance and then you might have
another model that was really easy on
and then you have a bunch of things in
between so my observation is it's kind
of like a mixed model or like if you
have longitudinal data that the the data
within a resample is more likely to be
correlated with each other than dated
between resamples and so it actually you
can calculate this from like a mixed
model or like the Bayesian model do in a
minute and the with NRI sample
correlation is 0.5 - which is pretty you
know not zero most likely and you know
and what you can see is in this graph on
the next page these the same data and
what I did is each line is a resample
and then you have the bagged model the
marsh model rain of forest and you can
see that surprisingly like bagging
didn't do all that well considering it's
very similar to rain of forests but what
the thing to notice about this in terms
of the correlation structure is that
we're good let's call this mob maybe
yeah okay
mob you know that resample was really
really easy for everybody and then you
have some down here like this
teal cyan maybe that one that you know
was relatively low for everybody and so
the the lines are not always parallel
these are roughly parallel there's some
of these resamples that are not like
rank order the same way but you can see
there is probably correlation structure
there that we need to account for in the
data like we would with a compared
t-test okay so any analysis of these
r-squared values ought to account for
that and so we'll do that as we go along
so here's the mathy part and i don't
think it's too bad
that if we were just thinking about like
an ANOVA model the typical way you would
write that down is you have some like
outcome you want a model as a function
of some indicator variables like are you
in Group 1 or group 2 group 3 and so the
math is on the left hand side we have
the R squared which is like our data now
and then we have an intercept and then
we have M 1 and M 2 which would be
indicators for our models like binary
indicator so M 1 might be an indicator
for the Mars model and MT might be the
zr1 indicator for random forests and
this is basically what an ANOVA model is
it's like a regression on indicator
variables now I haven't really talked
about you know the resamples there's no
like subscripts or I or anything like
that so the way you can think about this
is what we call random intercept model
is we're gonna say like at the wreath at
the resample bottom for a specific
reason
like r-squared sub I that they have some
random intercept that puts them
somewhere on that curve and then a non
systematic effect due to like model one
and model two ok so what we're going to
do is do what we call in like if
anybody's like a linear mixed model
person like a random intercept model
this is a really common like way to
account for correlation and data so the
sort of generative model here is that
we're gonna have effects due to the
models but like a random intercept and
that would account for this effect like
you know if we can think of these curves
as having roughly the same pattern but
it just shifts up and down depending on
the resample that's like a random
intercept model in it and I didn't pick
that because it happened to work out
this way this is really really typical
for these types of datasets so what I'm
going to do is I want to fit a Bayesian
hierarchical generalized linear model
it's a lot of words and what that means
is the r-squared is going to be a
function we're gonna say it's let's say
it's normally distributed with some
random intercept beta 0 and some you
know systemic effects for the models and
sums Sigma squared and so what we would
do in the Bayesian analysis is we would
put prior distributions on these
parameters and it's pretty common to and
that's what makes it a bayesian model is
we're saying that there's a statistical
distribution these parameters prior to
seeing the data and then what Bayesian
analysis does is it blends those prior
distributions with the actual data we
collected and merges them to somebody
we together to get what they call the
posterior distribution and I had a bunch
of titles for this talk that kind of got
rejected because there's a lot you can
do it's posterior as the title but what
this comes down to is we get like a
random intercept model so we can account
for the the within correlation problem
and then treat it like it's a linear
model right so we're going to model the
r-squared data now so that works pretty
well so I have this package called tidy
posterior that does this and it
basically used a stand to fit the model
and there's a lot of flexibility in
terms of how you do this so when I first
started thing about doing this I thought
well geez I have r-squared value you
know that's probably you know these are
bounded between 0 and 1 so you know I
probably shouldn't assume normality
about that right that's probably not a
good idea
but it turns out in many cases not this
particular one but you're okay using
normality and the idea is like the
central limit theorem we think of is as
we start looking at averages of data
points no matter what their distribution
is right central limit theorem tells it
that those averages as the data gets
bigger tend to convert to something that
looks more normal and basically our
squared root mean squared error or
things like that are almost like
averages of our individual data points
so they tend to behave pretty well so
you know there are times where you might
want to change the link function or you
might want to assume gamma distribution
you can do all that in the package what
I did here was the R squared values in
some cases were relatively close to one
and so what I didn't want to do is have
my posterior distribution saying you
could have an R squared of point you
know 1 point something so what I did is
I I pre transform the data on a logit
scale so logit would basically translate
to 0 1 values to you know potentially
negative infinity and infinity and then
do the data analysis on that and then
and so that's what the Bayesian analysis
is on is like the loge of the r-squared
values and then the cool thing is when
you get your posterior distributions
back you could just untransformed to get
back to the original unit so it doesn't
really cost you anything and that and my
experience is that is better than using
a low jetLink or something because just
convergence is more difficult that way
so here's the result so what happens is
you get these distributions for these
models and you can see these violin
plots which we're having dinner like
yesterday or last night and I was like I
hate violin plots I'm like
like good thing is not here right so
what you get out of this is you get like
these posterior distributions so you can
see the bagged model has a pretty wide
variance and maybe let's say it's the
center that distributions about like
0.79 so you know it maybe didn't do so
well but then for Mars and random forest
we random force is doing a little bit
better but just by a little bit maybe
and those distributions are a little bit
tighter the reason for the difference in
variation between those distributions is
because I put it on the logit scale so
you do a low jatt normal model basically
when you transform it back you're not
going to get a necessarily symmetric
data and it makes sense because the you
know for something between zero one you
would think that the variability in that
statistic is higher in the middle
because as you start pushing more and
more closer to zero one those
distribution should get compacted to
some degree so it's a it's a fairly
realistic at least to me it seems like
it makes a lot of sense so what you can
do is if you wanted to say okay well
let's say I like random forests you can
basically get credible intervals by
looking let's say percentiles of these
distributions and you can say oh you
know my random forest model I think the
true performance is about you know eight
point eighty nine point one percent it
could have been as high as like knotty
point five percent if it's like 90
percent interval or it could have been
you know with the 90 cent property bode
could have been as low as eighty-seven
point eight
all right so let you what's cool about
this is it lets you make comments
directly about the thing that you want
instead of like a confidence interval or
even worse like what a p-value would
give you it's like you have these like
convoluted interpretations where the
things we're trying to get to so the
thing about it is that you know I said
in the title practical differences and
so you know is you know if I'm comparing
Mars and random forests you know that's
like an maybe a 1 point something
percent difference in our square is that
a practical difference is it real so
what we can do is once we get the
posteriors for these things it's really
really easy to get the posterior of the
difference in r-squared okay and so what
you can do is now you can think about
well when I want to compare models I can
get like a Bayesian estimate of the
difference in R squared between these
models and then maybe put an interval on
that okay so what we can do is we can do
some things with the R squared now
there's this idea of like a rope
estimate and so a rope rope stands for
region of practical equivalence and what
these people thought of is
well let's say I put something before
start modeling I say okay you know I'm
looking at r-squared for house prices
what would be like if I had two models
without seeing the data if I two models
how big of an R squared difference what
I want to see to say that's a real
difference right and that's really
subjective so you might say one percent
so you might say five percent I decided
to say two percent so if let's say I had
a model it was like r-squared was like
point seven eight another one that was
point eight you know two percent
difference is probably practical enough
for me to feel like that's a real thing
okay it depends she just looked at me
like sketchy like a sigh died mates was
like no no no so but it is it is
subjective but what you can do is once
we get the posterior for the difference
between these things you can look at it
in terms of what is the two percent
difference realistic given the results
that we have and a big part of that's
the uncertainty that we're collecting so
if we're looking at random force versus
Mars here's what the posterior
difference or the the posterior of the
difference in r-squared between those
two models it is a slightly positive
because our random force does a little
bit better than Mars you can see the
tails of it maybe are around like I
don't know point point maybe oh three or
negative point or three it's roughly
symmetric if we were looking at
statistical significance like the old
school sort of significance we calculate
maybe how much of that distribution what
percentage of that probability
distribution is to the right of zero
right so that's saying is there any
difference between these models and you
can calculate that probability really
easily with the posterior but what the
dotted lines are the region of practical
equivalence and what that means is how
much of the posterior distribution is
within this plus or minus two percent
that I think is like within that two
percent it's not a real difference and
so what people typically do is they
calculate the percentage of the
posterior that's inside those bounds so
what they would say is in this
particular case ninety three point five
percent of that posteriors within plus
or minus two percent so you would say
the probability of practical equivalence
between these two models given sort of
like the yardstick up two percent is
really really high so based on that sort
of measure of what I think a real
difference is you would probably
conclude there's nothing different
between these two models right so you
would say it's not a big enough
difference for me to think it's you know
maybe it's statistically significant but
it's not practical equivalent and this
might be a big deal because if you're
thinking about this Mars is a really
really easy model to put in let's say
Excel or whatever you want the
prediction equation that's really nice
whereas random for us comes with you
know thousands of trees that have maybe
hundreds of splits and things like that
so you might have like a much faster
implementation of your prediction
equation that you've you know could
probably feel pretty good about it
having equal uncertainty or equal
performance to this other model okay so
that's all it does so basically the
package is called Teddy posterior and I
did it using results from this other
package called our sample that we've
written it also works with carrots so if
you're using carrot if you've used
carrot there's this function called
resamples
that collects all the resampling results
and analyzes it this is like the you
know resamples with like mag wheels it's
like the badass version of resamples and
it basically works the same way but
gives you different analysis results
you
you